In this problem, we'll be
working with a object called
random walk, where we have a
person on the line-- or a
tight rope, according
to the problem.
Let's start from the origin, and
each time step, it would
randomly either go forward
or backward with certain
probability.
In our case, with probability
P, the person would go
forward, and 1 minus
P going backwards.
Now, the walk is random in the
following sense-- that the
choice going forward or backward
in each step is
random, and it's completely
independent
from all past history.
So let's look at the problem.
It has three parts.
In the first part, we'd like to
know what's the probability
that after two steps the person
returns to the starting
point, which in this
case is 0?
Now, throughout this problem,
I'm going to be using the
following notation.
F indicates the action of going
forward and B indicates
the action of going backwards.
A sequence says F and B implies
the sample that the
person first goes forward,
and then backwards.
If I add another F, it will
mean, forward, backward,
forward again.
OK?
So in order for the person to
go somewhere after two steps
and return to the origin, the
following must happen.
Either the person went forward
followed by backward, or
backward followed by forward.
And indeed, this event--
namely, the union of these
two possibilities--
defines the event of interest
in our case.
And we'd like to know what's
the probability of A, which
we'll break down into the
probability of forward,
backward, backward, forward.
Now, forward, backward and
backward, forward-- they are
two completely different
outcomes.
And we know that because they're
disjoint, this would
just be the sum of the
two probabilities--
plus probability of
backward/forward.
Here's where the independence
will come in.
When we try to compute the
probability of going forward
and backward, because
the action--
each step is completely
independent from the past, we
know this is the same as saying,
in the first step, we
have probability P of going
forward, in the next step,
probability 1 minus P
of going backwards.
We can do so-- namely, writing
the probability of forward,
backward as a product of going
forward times the probability
of going backwards, because
these actions are independent.
And similarly, for the second
one, we have going backwards
first, times going forward
the second time.
Adding these two up, we have 2
times P times 1 minus P. And
that will be the answer to the
first part of the problem.
In the second part of the
problem, we're interested in
the probability that after three
steps, the person ends
up in position 1, or
one step forward
compared to where he started.
Now, the only possibilities here
are that among the three
steps, exactly two steps are
forward, and one step is
backwards, because otherwise
there's no way the person will
end up in position 1.
To do so, there, again, are
three possibilities in which
we go forward, forward,
backward, or forward,
backward, forward, or backward,
forward, forward.
And that exhausts all the
possibilities that the person
can end up in position
1 after three steps.
And we'll define the collection
of all these
outcomes as event C. The
probability of event C--
same as before--
is simply the sum of
the probability of
each individual outcome.
Now, based on the independence
assumption that we used
before, each outcome here has
the same probability, which is
equal to P squared times 1 minus
P. The P squared comes
from the fact that two forward
steps are taken, and 1 minus
P, the probability of that
one backwards step.
And since there are three of
them, we multiply 3 in front,
and that will give us
the probability.
In the last part of the problem,
we're asked to
compute that, conditional on
event C already took place,
what is the probability that the
first step he took was a
forward step?
Without going into the details,
let's take a look at
the C, in which we have three
elements, and only the first
two elements correspond
to a forward step
in the first step.
So we can define event
D as simply
the first two outcomes--
forward, forward, backward, and
forward, backward, forward.
Now, the probability we're
interested in is simply
probability of D conditional on
C. We'd write it out using
the law of conditional
probability--
D intersection C conditional
on C. Now, because D is a
subset of C, we have probability
of D divided by
the probability of C.
Again, because all samples
here have the same
probability, all we need to do
is to count the number of
samples here, which is 2, and
divide by the number of
samples here, which is 3.
So we end up with 2 over 3.
And that concludes
the problem.
See you next time.